I don't pay taxes and I don't save money
and I use debt to get rich and I don't
have those in the stock market that's
why I'm rich the opportunity for self
education is that we have to change our
psychology from I'm gonna do what
everybody else does and I'm mad because
it doesn't work anymore - the reality is
this the greatest time to be alive if
you're growing you're learning you're
educating and you're developing valuable
skills you know that every living soul
it's exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time wanna be
happy
build a life not just a business
you and I believe life ball
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how you can
stay relevant so the future doesn't
destroy you
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one question everything with
Robert Kiyosaki I think most of your
viewers out there sitting inside their
head or their words from their mother
and father go to school get a job pay
taxes save money buy a house cause it's
an asset get out of debt yeah and invest
in the stock market that creates poor
people it's a hypnosis train going
through your brain so when people say
how do I change my life or you change
those words I wouldn't go to school
because you learn nothing about money in
school ask I wouldn't get a job because
if I have a job I'm an employee and then
I'd pay taxes and I don't pay taxes and
I don't save money and I use debt to get
rich and I don't invest in the stock
market that's why I'm rich and so the
young people who are listening right now
they're saying but that's what my mom
and dad said but that's what mom and dad
say all over the world so to the young
people I just say challenge or question
what you've been taught because from the
Bible I'm not religious yeah the word
becomes flesh so if you say go to school
he's but I'll learn nothing about money
get a job you become an employee yeah if
you're an employee you work for money I
pay taxes then they tell you to save
money why would you save money when the
government's printing money you know and
get out of debt
well debt is money I use debt to get
rich most videos debt to get poor and
then fast in the stock market I don't
invest in the stock
market so when you when you wonder why
so many people struggle financially as
they haven't challenged the hypnosis the
words go to school get a job work hard
save money get pay taxes until you
question those hypnotic trances you
don't change rule number two
constantly improve yourself with Tony
Robbins hey can you don't have a
standard education and expect to have an
extraordinary life it's not gonna happen
the one breakthrough for all leaders is
constant never-ending improvement and
that means educating yourself and
continuing to develop even greater
emotional mastery because that's what
affects whether you execute enough the
opportunity for self education is there
we have to change our psychology from
I'm gonna do what everybody else does
and I'm mad because it doesn't work
anymore - the reality is this the
greatest time to be alive
if you're growing you're learning you're
educating and you're developing valuable
skills so instead of complaining you
gotta say where are the skill sets
valued in the marketplace and how do I
work harder on myself than anything else
because if I become more valuable then I
will be able to give more do more and
change more when I interviewed Warren
Buffett ask the most important
investment you ever made in his life he
already said it was I was thinking of
all the companies I've done you know he
said Tony going to Dale Carnegie said
what he goes because by developing
myself that's the most important
investment those skill sets learning how
to persuade learning how to speak
learning and influence all my ideas
would've died on my lips
if I hadn't be able to influence and I
learned it from that little course the
most valuable thing I ever did in my
life he said also if you want to have
more confident self love and motivation
check out my to 54 series they're free
the link to join on the description
below so if you want to change your life
my friends you've got to change your
physiology and you got to change your
focus when you're trying to get wealthy
you want to literally you want to go
all-in and it not be a bet you need to
know the space so well then you're like
I know for sure this was gonna work most
PhD is tell me I can't write yes I said
I can't write but I can't sell rule
number three keep up with innovations
with Jordan Peterson I made a decision
when the computers started to become
present and so that would have been
about 1993 that I was going to spend a
year and that was the first year that I
was teaching in Boston pretty much doing
nothing but figuring out how Intel 486
has worked and it meant there was a lot
of other things that I had to put on
hold but I did become a competent
computer user and I was I'm pretty fast
but you know my son it's just annoying
as hell to watch him on the computer and
on the phone because and my graduate
students as well because there's so much
faster than me that it's not even funny
and I'm not really accustomed to being
slower than someone else in the room and
so you know if I had children now the
one thing I would bloody well make sure
that they knew was how to use a computer
how to program man because if you're
smart and you can use a computer you are
so much smarter than you are if you're
just smart that it's not even funny you
know and you talk to people you service
in Silicon Valley all the time you talk
to people who are expert computer users
they are so bloody powerful it is just
beyond belief so and that that's gonna
do nothing but expand right because
Moore's law is not dead and computers
are doubling in power every 18 months
and and so and who the hell knows where
that's going to go rule number four
manage your activities with Bob Proctor
think of this for a moment do you know
that every living soul gets exactly the
same amount of time exactly the same
amount of time figure it out
you get all there is a hobo sleeping
under a bridge or on a park bench there
is no material possessions none does
nothing of any constructive nature that
person gets exactly the same amount of
time as the most productive
industrialist in the world we all get
exactly the same amount of time so it's
what we do with the time that makes a
difference I want you to think of the
number of time management programs
almost everyone under the Sun has time
management
programs in fact I made one one time
spent a lot of money on it and then I
found out it was a dumb waste of time
and money do you know why time can't be
managed I was having breakfast with
rural Nightingale one morning and it was
downtown Chicago and I was going with
him on his speaking engagement and it
was early in the morning he said you
want to meet for breakfast whenever I'll
Nigel said you want to meet me I was
there and I always had some
well-prepared questions and I remember
asked him I said to him how did you
learn how to master time management yeah
we're having breakfast I can still hear
his fork hit the plate he's what the
hell are you talking about
he's I've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
he's I merely manage activity and he
took a little card out of his pocket and
he said every night before I go to bed I
write down six most important things I
have to do tomorrow these are goal
achieving activities and when I wake up
that's when I start working on and if I
don't get them all done I'll add them to
tomorrow's list you should have about
six now if I have three that I didn't
get done today that doesn't mean I have
nine for tomorrow like six plus these
three those three become part of the six
you have to do the next day when you
wake up you give all your conscious
attention to do those things so you
cannot manage time but you can manage
activity you can manage your activities
make certain that what you're doing
really makes a difference make certain
that you're spending your time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
and you'll number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
always keep learning with Mark Cuban
what is your thing and when did you kind
of understand what it hasn't changed my
thing is learning learning whatever is
new and applying it in ways that other
people aren't thinking of and so when I
start I got fired from a job selling
software started a company and within
six months it's the early days of PCs I
recognized that ok we need to connect
pcs together back man you walked around
you had your 500 or inch
copy and you know who would need to
connect the PC we started you know
writing software for local area networks
became a systems integrator 30-some
million dollar run right and sold it to
H&R Block and then got to the internet
okay let's look at this internet thing
someone's gonna need to put audio and
then video on there great and then after
Yahoo did Yahoo right I'm like you know
what I'm looking at these big screen TVs
that cost thirty thousand dollars that
are high-definition television sets and
I'm thinking you know what eventually
they're gonna follow the price
performance curve of traditional of
traditional consumer electronics and
they're gonna come down a price so I
started the first all high-definition TV
network called HD net then I'm looking
and saying okay you know what it's like
2006-2007 and traditional television and
cable is going digital I'm saying you
know what there's going to be more a lot
of storage space than first access
digital space that cable companies
aren't used to using so let's take a
movie production company that we created
and let's make it available for day and
date distribution where people can will
pay 20 bucks to the the cable company to
watch this brand-new movie and we get to
keep ten of it and so we had twenty nine
twenty nine productions we started
producing movies and what would behold
the first movie we created was a
documentary called Enron the smartest
guys in the room got nominated for
Academy Award then we didn't really
create any good ones after that but by
being first leveraging digital storage
we were able to take advantage and make
a lot of money and in the NBA with the
Mavericks you know just doing those
types of things and it's what I like to
do now and so you know now I'm going
through and teaching myself neural
networks and you know doing the same
thing with machine learning and Ganz and
this and that because AI is going to
have more of an impact than the internet
did AI plus new types of chipsets plus
five G is going to change things far
more than we've ever seen anything
change and understanding where and how
to apply it is going to be critical but
just as important knowing how to sub
segregate and separate the boss yeah
right is it as important because every
email y'all are about to send me is
going to say I have this AI solution and
we're using algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if I
didn't do that work if I just sit down
and do the AWS machine learning
tutorials if I didn't go on YouTube and
take you know the NYU introduction to
neural networks or whatever I'm not
gonna know it I'm not gonna be able to
apply it and I'm not gonna be able to be
first and that's fun that's but no one I
get to kick ass I'm 22 year old NYU
graduate that's awesome yeah
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Grant Cardone on how to study success
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that is time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question boy
what new thing will you commit to
learning this month number two what
activities do you need to manage better
and number three what can you improve in
yourself this week people should be
studying the most successful companies
in the world not not individuals don't
worry about Dave or Gary or Tony or
grant what are successful people doing
you know I the one of the biggest
mistakes I've made in my life was
tracking people that were doing better
than me so what like like like like I
made so many dumbass decisions because
Dave did it or The Millionaire Next Door
that that book I don't want to be the
millionaire next door I want to know
what Jeff besos is doing I want to know
what the boys at Google are doing it
okay why why does a guy like Mark
Zuckerberg go from college dorm room to
one of the richest people on the planet
that's who we should be studied and and
don't listen to everybody else because
those people have financial freedom to
the point to where they they can do
anything they want like you cannot mess
up some of these people's situation they
couldn't screw it up if they wanted to
so the 10x rule is is a it says hey look
you want to scale to a point to where
you have the life you deserve it's not
about the money you
or the money you need scale your
business so you can walk away from it
and money never stops taking care of you
and your family you don't need to study
27 different warrants you study one more
and you're probably going to be good
most of us because of Instagram and
Facebook and YouTube we're listening to
so many different people then that
people do nothing this this is a new
crisis of our era people are doing
nothing not because they're lazy because
they have data that is conflicting so if
you listen to Dave dave says buy a house
then you listen to grant Grant says
that's stupid you're not gonna do
anything and if you're never gonna buy
any real estate hey go ahead and buy one
house yeah you're gonna regret it later
and you're gonna be like I wish I had
done what Cardone said but but you got
to do something and what you don't want
to do is listen to God and the devil
because then you get stuck in purgatory
and you don't have any fun at all
if you want to see the top ten best
rules of the decade check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I think I feel feel fear quite strongly
so it's not as though I just have the
absence of fear I've